love this man I don't care even if he's
not sitting here I'd say these in his
14th season 14th season is Dodgers
play-by-play announcer man oh I met back
in 1996 and I walked into the ESPN
newsroom
my fellow former SportsCenter compadre
and Los Angeles Dodgers broadcaster
Charley Steiner good to see you sir one
of the really great things about this
time of year a yes by employer the
Dodgers are doing well yeah B I last
week I got a chance to talk with Dan on
his on his radio show in the last few
days I got to see boomer Chris Berman
who was doing the Dodger brave games on
ESPN so it's it's been like this reunion
week and it's wonderful to see you do
you mind I've right back at you do you
mind if I ask you what what do you and
Berman talk about when you're in like
having a you know again we have little
time to spend who are getting ready for
our respective games sure and it's more
you know walking down memory lane and it
really is wonderful to see them I got
there in 88 and so we've known each
other 30 years and you know it's it's
very simple much like with Dan and with
you you just pick up conversations where
you left off it's completely seamless
and effortless and it's wonderful to see
so we're great to talk to Dan I told the
first time a long time which is what you
generally say - yeah - radio host so for
us it's many time long yeah it isn't
that and it is indeed but when you when
you first started to do - people say
first time long time when they called in
- like but wow
wor whatever you were on in New York
City or you know that relatively
speaking that's new I didn't thought
about that yesterday when the first time
somebody actually said first time long
time like hey great ideas but yeah I
don't remote I didn't circle the day on
the couch okay but it's been a while I
love it
the Honda insider report is we're gonna
get some quality and some bad
information from Charlie Schneider here
prior to the NL CS y game one for
Kershaw do you think is it choice
because it's Kershaw
Clayton Kershaw is the heart and soul of
this franchise he's been here for a
decade
and if there is any doubt about pitching
game one his performance the other night
put all of that to rest Ryu has been
great Bueller has been you know off the
charts and Rich Hill is a very suitable
number four so you go with you go with
the king now you know I think it just he
did so well in a game - I mean it's
silly obviously every state where Dave
Roberts must have every metric in front
of him and then he's got the gut of his
experience for which he's won an award
look one of the things about Dave and
I've said this really from from the day
he arrived he is a very cerebral manager
who has a great sense of the pulse of
his clubhouse he knows how to deal with
the media as well as any manager I've
been around I've been around Joe Torian
and many others who can handle the mic
and handle the camera this was an issue
he simply did not need or want
and based on Clayton's last performance
and apparently he was a little torque
that he was number two and not number
one he proved that he is still king of
the hill and what a better fallback
position than having real pitch game -
and the other thing dating back to my
Yankee days
guess who pitched the second game of big
series virtually everyone Andy Pettitte
why Torre felt that either
Cena or Clemens if he won Game one now
they're up to if they tried
Pettit out and more times than not they
were and plus you have to say lost the
first one right now they're all even
again and so now you've got Rios got an
e ra of under two as your number two guy
right who's gonna pitch twice to me it
was just a natural thing to say and do
well Pettit also did really well on the
road right I mean like see you got to
get somebody that you know can also
handle the crucible if you're starting
for some reason to serve as much like
Pettit Ruiz a grown up been down the
road before he can handle all
this so what's fascinating about this
series it seems to me hmm is that both
teams are peaking at precisely the right
time
Dodgers wins seven of their last eight
and outscored the opposition out of 47
15 whatever the number was then you've
got Milwaukee they've won 11 straight
and they just beat up on Colorado and
the Rockies to some degree were
victimized by the wild card game that
always unsettles a rotation so you got
two great teams peaking at the right
time but this is gonna be a wonderful
series
Charley Steiner here on the Rich Eisen
show prior to getting on a flight for of
the Waukee game one is gonna be on Fox
coming up on Friday night and then
Saturday afternoon in Milwaukee for Game
two so what do you think is the biggest
issue going through Dave Roberts mind
knowing how hot Milwaukee is and their
pitching staff what do you think is the
biggest problem that's presented to the
Dodgers I don't know that there's really
a problem you know you go back to Herman
and would you play to win the game what
what I think watching these two teams it
will be more imperative than usual to
score early especially because of
Milwaukee's bullpen see we try to maybe
the best that kid hater is simple oh and
Jeffers is great you know so I think the
Dodgers want length out of their
rotation and if they can do that then
ideally or theoretically they will have
a lead and I think that it'll be the
Dodger starters their effectiveness
I think against the effectiveness of the
brewer bullpen and if the Dodgers don't
allow the brewer bullpen to get quality
time then they're in pretty good shape
score and early Charlie stoner here on
the Rich Eisen show how is Kenley Jansen
it does appear over his last couple of
outings that the Jansen from last year
is returned would you agree with that
we'll all find out together you know
it's
it's been a rugged year for Kenley but
securing the final out in Atlanta the
other night was was a big deal and again
the nice thing now is disregard the
previous hundred and sixty something
games they don't count anymore now it's
a seven game series and Don Zimmer
legendarily would tell Joe Torre once
you get to this point in the season you
win one inning at a time then you go to
the next inning and then by the end of
the night you've got a nine inning
tapestry and I think so if the Dodgers
are able to get to him why not it seems
it's it's amazing you you brought that
up with Zimmer and what he you said just
two old guys old school guys saying
something it seems now though with the
analytics world that going from inning
to inning means starting your bullpen
and or making sure your starter doesn't
see the road lineup for a third straight
time regardless of score and regardless
of pitch count it seems it's just gotten
a little bit over the top
yes queued what is your perspective on
that I see it a lot of it depends on how
the team is constructed and again I
think the Dodgers have a better rotation
than Milwaukee has I think their
strength is the backend of their bullpen
and how you get to the ninth inning is
dependent upon how you have pieced your
team together
look at if one of the reasons why the
Dodgers beat Atlanta was that Kershaw
went seven seven or eight innings so
yeah and and so did Ryu and and so if
you're effective that way then fine I
don't know that Craig Counsell is as
confident in his rotation as Davis in
his but he has every reason to be
confident with his bullpen at the end of
the day you just look at the numbers how
do you get there
the object of the game is really simple
beat the other guy by at least a rock do
it and then you would right I mean we
had Harold Reynolds on yesterday and he
said that with Dave Robertson this
Dodger lineup that they essentially are
all fungible with the exception of
Justin Turner and Mankato that those two
guys go to the they go to the stadium
every day no one there in everyone else
looks at their phone he says to see if
he's get they're getting the text from
from management saying you're out today
or you're in today I think it took a
while in September for all of that to
come together you know kudos to Andrew
and Farhan it referred in Farhan xiety
they realized at the end of August it
was gonna be a one-month sprint to the
finish line and then they went out and
got David Freese they had already gotten
Machado and Ryan Madson they had to beat
Colorado which they did by one game game
163 so now here we are into the
postseason David Freese had the big hit
the other night and Freese is a
postseason hero 2011 NLCS MVP in the
World Series MVP he knows the big
situation Matson came in the other night
bases-loaded one out and retired the
next two and that basically ended the
game and Machado is one of the top five
or ten talents in the game so you've got
these people who now it took a while for
them to understand how this these
interchangeable parts were going to work
and my sense is about the middle of
September finally they all kind of
bought in okay this is this is how it's
going this is how it's happening and
this is how ultimately it is working and
I think right I don't think there was
any one given day where the Dodgers
suddenly turned on the switch and okay
follow me to freedom if I can you may
drop that in you may but it was it was a
gradual thing and then about the middle
of September they had a 10 game road
trip three in Colorado or was it Arizona
I forget now the three in Cincinnati and
finished up with four mmm in st. Louis
and then after a Sunday night game we
had three with Colorado it was in that
period of time a 10 game road trip we
won six out of ten and then after the
road trip in that Sunday night game we
swept Colorado three straight at that
point I got the sense that yeah this
team is really coagulating coming
together Charley Steiner here on the
Rich Eisen show and the Honda insider
report a few more minutes left with you
sir you got a good GU curse story now
that you're gonna see him over the next
several days weeks you've been around
some of the old-time great ones Charlie
he's the only one on earth who calls me
chassis boy chassis boy I don't know why
but again he is one of the American
treasures you know he was a guest on
Johnny Carson more than any other guest
I heard that he really was number one
Bob Uecker more than anybody else that
and he has natural comedic timing and we
had dinner few years back in Milwaukee
imagine that and I asked him about it he
said you know him when he was playing he
used to go to like catch a rising star
whatever the comedy joints were in New
York and he would quietly do stand-up no
way just like open mic night there's Bob
Uecker much you know you Bob Uecker
wasn't Bob Uecker yet right but you sit
with him
whether it's dinner visiting in the
booth for a few minutes just hobnobbing
he is as naturally funny as any human
being I've ever been around and it's a
big moment for the Brewers and he's I
mean he's he's doing interviews after
the game too I love seeing it he's you
could see like he's really prideful
about what's happening with their ores
right now it's all right yes this is he
is the absolute hometown hero and
there's nothing not to love about Bob
Uecker yeah
and that'll be if I'm looking forward to
this NLCS you get you taken on a flight
tomorrow walking on the flight tomorrow
okay we just showed a sports center spot
moments ago here view with the Christy
Martin the boxer and you having some
sort of love affair with her if you will
from the SportsCenter days think of it
as a docudrama it's amazing I'm out of
it for now it being ESPN four cheese now
15 years and I still get people thinking
I'm on sports over you and me both you
would get that all the time still still
you know the last SportsCenter you did
late 2001 so it's 17 years because I
know towards the end of my tenure there
you were the voice of ESPN radio
baseball doing some fine you know yeah
put on the fights too I took over for
you when you stepped away from the
Sports Center fight oh I did the sports
centers after you're like okay I'm done
with that been there done that
I stepped in and I was a little
disappointed I'll be very honest with
you because they stopped the the you
must wear a tuxedo for the Sports Center
I felt like a valet fight but the last
fight I did yeah was a Tyson Holyfield
and the bite and I had wanted out for a
long time and so on this night Tyson
famously takes a chunk out of
Holyfield's ear and I looked into the
camera the last words I uttered and
covering a fight for ESPN Evander
Holyfield and a portion of his right ear
were rushed to the hospital tonight
in separate cars true and now is it back
to you in the studio that's it thank you
good night
that's a mic job that's a walk
that was it thank you good night and all
holy heck had broken loose in Vegas
right when you wrote this is it summing
up the entire evening that was it
oh I thought yeah then the three tonight
you know I again I had wanted it off for
about a year because I saw the the
future of the sport and the horizon was
flat and I had gone to our boss Howard
Katz god-blessed mm-hmm now Howard I
can't do this anymore Syd give me one
more year we will find a substitute for
you that's by the way I raised my right
hand you me sucker and so because I
wanted to devote my time to baseball I
felt like boxing had run its course and
I think history shows that it did
occasionally there is a good fight now
but it is not in the caliber of those
days
sure so on the Monday morning after a
portion of his right ear were rushed to
the hospital in separate cars
I walk into Howard's office in Bristol
and he said don't say another word
you are free of your burden onto
baseballs and thank you and then I did
hold a field more or two uh-huh and the
fight where Henry Aachen one day had to
cancel because he had a case of
hepatitis so that's what you missed
Charley turns dear Aachen one day was
dyslexic and he couldn't spell his name
oh man Charley Steiner here on the Honda
inside a report again brought to you by
the Honda Odyssey
it's the perfect minivan for any family
man with available magic slide seats and
cabin watch it's never been easier to
keep the peace from your kids get a
little too out of hand so be sure to
visit your local Honda dealer today
thank you for coming on Charlie Storrs
great or the man let's-- I would love to
just have you on when you're done with
the season and you have done whatever
you need to do to wind down come on and
just go straight memory lane with
everything else all right I'd love to do
that all right
2000 2021 we're good okay
that's when you're winding down yes you
wind up everything soon as the season's
over
okay very good that's Charlie stunner
safe travels sir thank you sir and I
will I think I'm bringing the the kids
out to the stadium on Monday night these
bring your wife happy I am in fact the
time I go that's the old New York Mets
oh my gosh as when um et me right there
but you're not allowed to sing that song
from being from Boston yeah but I know I
just know it I have a lot of met fan
friends oh you do well you just watch
the songs by the way I'm dancer worth it
good to see you Charlie Stein that's
always oh you got it the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience